Je suis content d'être monté dans cette voiture avec vous toutes les
caméras
J'accentue le partenariat Transformers a
commencé il y a dix ans avec les premiers
Transformers et le partenariat a
gagné en popularité tout au long de chacun
IMAX me donne les outils pour vous offrir la
meilleure expérience cinématographique en  le monde
Transformers a été une partie géante de
notre marque, il a aidé à construire IMAX
Michael nous a poussés à être plus agiles
donc plus petits mais sans compromettre la
résolution il nous a poussés à ce que la 3d
soit plus transparente il essaie constamment
d'augmenter l'expérience cinématographique
me donne 3d  ici
sur ce film transformers hier soir
nous tournons avec IMAX 3d et les
résultats sont phénoménaux Michael est le
tout premier cinéaste à prendre deux de
ces caméras et à les configurer sur une
plate-forme 3d et à filmer en 3d en temps réel et
ce n'est pas anodin la résolution  le
détail la clarté c'est
vraiment époustouflant nous utilisons toute la
technologie IMAX pour vous offrir la meilleure
expérience que vous verrez cette année
vous